the Democratic party I grew up in always
had trouble fundraising because the the
the the groups that it could fundraise
were very limited they could fund raise
from trial
lawyers they could fund raise from
unions and but most of the big
corporations um were were off limits to
them you know a really pure Democrat
wouldn't take any corporate money which
meant you know it's hard to win
elections meanwhile the big money you
know um was going from the uh from the
oil industry the coal industry the
pesticide industry the big food big a
industry was mainly going to Republicans
there were a lot of Midwestern a you
know aate Democrats that were taking
money from Gill and Monsanto and
Smithfield and Purdue and Bo Pilgrim Etc
but on Democrats wouldn't take
pharmaceutical
money
I thought we'd start with something a
little a little bizarre because
obviously there's plenty to talk about
and the world seems to be in a bit of a
chaotic place but on the way here as I
was in the car I looked at your Twitter
and I want to read your last tweet
because I think this encapsulates a lot
of people's frustrations with what's
going on here in California uh you wrote
yesterday an intruder climbed the fence
at my home and was arrested after being
released from police custody later in
the day he immediately returned to my
home and was arrested
again so twice in one day at your house
you mentioned that your wife charl was
doing a Facebook live stream at that
moment um is that a perfect example of
the frustrations that people are having
in this town in this state and and
really really across the country at this
point yeah I I was cuz you were with me
a few minutes ago when I learned that
that was up on my Twitter and I didn't
really want to put it up on on my
Twitter cuz I didn't want to seem like I
was whining but um my wife uh saw him
come over the fence when she was doing a
Twitter space with I mean a a a Facebook
live uh or Instagram live um and and
then she saw the these wonderful guys
from Gavin Becker the security guys with
their guns drawn chasing him and and
putting U handcuffs on him but he was
got an intruder who had written over 400
emails um over the recent months
including many menacing ones a uh a week
ago one that threatened to put a bullet
in my head um and so you know it was a
it's one of of several incidences that
happened
recently including a guy who showed up
at um in La at a uh at at a theater in
Wilshire where I was doing a rally and
asked for me and he was wearing a US
Marshall badge um a a lanyard badge and
a um a federal
ID and he uh these guys spotted him
because they thought the badge was too
shiny and he asked to see
me and they uh they pulled him aside he
had two shoulder holsters on that were
fully loaded with uh each one with the
magazines loaded with eight bullets he
had a backpack on with another gun in it
loaded and he had I think four or five
extra magazines and KN knives and other
weapons in there and and his house later
on was filled with rifles and uh and he
gave it and he had given a Tik Tock
created a Tik talk that said if I don't
come back from this um you know contact
your commander and chief Etc so it was
um um you know we've repeatedly asked
the Biden Administration for Secret
Service protection I'm the the only
candidate in
history who has asked for a presidential
candidate who has requested Secret
Service protection and been
denied um most people get you they
legally have to give it to you 120 days
out but customarily is given my uncle
got it 500 Days out Teddy Aunt Kennedy
you know they they made secret service
available to candidates before during
the primaries after my father was killed
and ever since then people are are just
uh
proforma given I I think Obama got it
500 Days out I'm now you know 365 days
out so many many candidates have gotten
in much earlier than me it's disturbing
to me because I'm watching
the politicization of the other law
enforcement
agencies and when my father got into the
justice department the first day in the
Justice Department he called all the
attorneys together and the the one thing
he said to him is we are not going to do
we are not going to politicize Justice
in this
country and during my tenure at this
agency that there's going to be no
politization you know Democrats and
Republicans are going to be treated the
same and he gave that as an ironclad
order President Biden has a statue of my
father behind
him um in the Oval Office and uh but and
his family members
Secret Service
protection Anthony fouchy has a million
dollars of Secret Service protection a
month um you know and I people don't
like him so he you know he's entitled to
it John Bolton years after retiring as
Secret Service protection as do many
other
officials uh and it's a it's
politization you know I I I imagine I
don't know why they're doing it exactly
but I think think that they understand
it's very very expensive for me and that
they'd rather me be spending money on my
protection rather than you know on
advertisements or organization or field
organization uh so that's wrong now I I
want to say I just want to say this that
I'm involved in a number of lawsuits
against the administration against the
government and
against one of those suits is now in
front of the Supreme Court Kennedy
versus B
yes and um and that uh and and it has a
companion case Missouri versus Biden we
got a lower court decision from Judge
Dodie that's 155 pages long that
decision is you know Americans should
have to read it in civic's class because
it shows what happens when you
politicize the the law enforcement
agencies I it shows that President Biden
I was the first person censored by the
administration 37 hours after he took
the oath of office President Biden of
the White House was ordering Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram to remote my
accounts and threatening them that if
they did not do so that they were going
to the White House was going to try to
remove their section 230 immunity which
is existential for them they could not
they their companies would
die if they didn't have that section 23
immunity and what we found from the
Twitter files and from these from our
Discovery documents
is that the white house because of
pressure from the White House Facebook
and the other social media sites
provided portals to the FBI to go in
directly and sensor material and the FBI
gave access to the
CIA the DHS to the IRS and to about 12
other federal agencies so you had you
know listen I've been censored for 18
years
but not officially by the
government and you know the New York
Times and CNN CNN won't put me on N none
of them will do that but they're allowed
to that's not that does not violate the
First Amendment if you own a printing
press you can choose what to print and
what not to print if you own a uh a t a
cable station you know you're not using
the airwaves if you go on a cable
station you can decide what to censor
and not to
censor when the government
begins telling you to censor things now
the first amendment is implicated
because that's exactly why we passed the
First Amendment to make sure that the
government could not silence its critics
and I and I'll say the last thing
that a government thinking silence its
critics has license for every atrocity
because uh you know if you can if you
can quiet criticism about yourself
there's no end to the power that you can
then
claim
[Applause]
W so I guess that's a great segue you
know I know a lot of people obviously
want to talk about what's going on in
Israel and we'll we'll get to that but
that's a great segue
to what has happened to the Democrat
Party you know the day that you
announced I said on my show and my
audience tends to lean a little more
conservative now I said to my Audience
by the end of this thing I don't know
that he will be a republican but he will
not be a Democrat and you are now
running independent you I I said it on
my show we'll we'll send you the clip I
said it the day you announced it was
obvious I had seen Dennis mentioned the
the why I left the left video that I did
I I've seen that path even just from
chatting to some of the people here this
evening they're on that path as well I
think a lot of people are waking up but
what do you think happened really to
that party that has led to the
radicalism Andor I would argue utter
incompetence that that we're seeing
right
now no I I think a couple of things
happen one is
um uh they you know the the Democratic
party was interesting because the
Democratic party I grew up in could not
I watched this Evolution happen because
I was involved in the medical Freedom
issues and it and that was really the
spear tip of what happened to the
Democratic party and the Democratic
party I grew up in always had trouble
fundraising because there the the the
groups that it could fund raise were
very limited they could fund raise from
trial
lawyers they could fund raise from
unions and but most of the big
corporations um were were off limits to
them you know really pure Democrat
wouldn't take any corporate money which
meant you know it's hard to win
elections meanwhile the big money you
know um was going from the uh from the
oil industry the coal industry the PES
side industry the big food big EG
industry was mainly going to Republicans
there were a lot of Midwestern EG you
know aate Democrats that were taking
money from Gill and Monsanto and
Smithfield and Purdue and Bo Pilgrim Etc
but on Democrats wouldn't take
pharmaceutical money and then when in
2016 when they were fighting when
President Obama was fighting over
Obamacare or you know the in the Years
preceding 2012 to
2016 the Democrats um the Obama
administration had to make a deal with
the pharmaceutical companies in order to
get uh in order to get ObamaCare through
because if the farm is the biggest Lobby
is on capitalo and they could block it
they have
more they they pay twice in lobbying
what the next biggest which is oil and
gas and about five times what the
military contractors pay so they're they
are off the charts in which they and how
much they invest in
lobbying and the Obama administration
had to make a deal with them and the
deal they made is that we're going to do
Obamacare and we are going to buy your
without bargaining we're going to we're
going to buy everybody your drugs and
you're going to get really rich and uh
we won't barking for them we won't you
know push you down so they they got them
on
board at that point it became
permissible for Democrats to take
pharmaceutical money and they just
started taking it if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell